check this out this is a local news
report and at a school in California
school officials are freaking out
because they wanted to have a pride day
where everyone was going to have to wear
pride shirts and they were going to be
Pride Flags I don't know what this has
to do with being in school or anything
else or why state workers feel that they
should be talking to kids about sex and
genitals and all that stuff but the kids
the kids themselves a certain percentage
of the kids did not want to do it and
they protested and now the teachers in
the administration are freaking out and
it made the local news
place of intolerance and homophobia are
unacceptable this type of intolerant
rhetoric starts in the home parents
angry at Town Hall over intolerance at
Marshall Simons Middle School kids were
asked to wear Rainbow clothes in honor
of Pride Spirit day but some organized a
counter protest wearing red white and
blue or black the principal sharing a
statement to families that Pride posters
were ripped down stickers ripped up some
students chanted USA are my pronouns and
students showing Pride were intimidated
it was an unruly disruption in fact that
was organized ahead of time while some
parents were upset others say it was
overblown some of the kids threw the
stickers on the ground but you know I
can only speak for my daughter she just
she didn't want to wear that to school
it's not that she wanted to hurt
anybody's feelings she says her daughter
felt coerced to participate in the pride
event and was offended by some of the
messages like this quote from Tennessee
Williams human heart cannot be streeted
as curves and wines and my daughter just
kind of said you know Mom that's that's
offensive to to me who I am good for
that mother good for that daughter the
mother will probably be considered a
white supremacist soon enough and have
Los Angeles or California it's not Los
Angeles uh we'll have California state
officials at their doorstep looking into
their taxes and everything else but all
some of these kids some of these kids
took the took the freaking stickers off
that's all and now it's hate and they're
bigots everything else
foreign
[Music]